في اخبار السودان لا يزال السودان يا انه
تحت وطاه اقتتال يابى ان ينتهي فبعد
تفاؤلا ساد الخرطوم الايام الفائته
بالتزام طرفي الصراع بهدنه قد تقود وقتها
لوقت لوقف دائما للنار عاد القصف المدفعي
ليقطع احلام السودانيين في ام درمان الجيش
السوداني علق مشاركته في مفاوضات جده دون
الانسحاب منها مبررا قراره بعدم التزام
قوات الدعم السريع ببنود الهدنه وانه لا
معنى الاستمرار في تمديدها
الخارجيه السودانيه قالت ان قوات دعم
السريع استغلت الهدنه لشن الهجمات وسعت
لادخال اسلحه ومقاتلين لمناطق عده في
العاصمه وخارجها الطيران الحرب عاد
للتحليق في سماء الخرطوم بعد الشبكات سادت
منطقه المهندسين في ام درمان ساحه
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع اتسعت
مجددا خارج العاصمه حيث نشر الجيش
السوداني مقطعا مصورا لقواته في مدينه
الاوبيض في ولايه شمال كردفان مؤكدا انه
تصدى لهجوما من قوات دعم السريع على
المدينه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات